you
there we go all right we got another 15
to game
let's try D floors or start yeah okay
so 15 to game uh-huh the Dutch okay
I'd have 3 or C 4
I know it's C 4 sometimes there's a
reason to go with the night age 3 night
age 3 to f4 I've seen stuff like that
before hmm I might want to go with
Bishop g2 g3 Bishop g2 sometimes there's
a reason to not go forward with Knight
c3 to avoid Bishop b4 pins so I'm gonna
hold off on this and I'm gonna get on
this dog and I'll be for black hits on
it that's the big plan okay well I don't
have to worry about Bishop before the
bishops come here so these two moves are
probably interchangeable doesn't really
matter Bishop g2 Knight c3 and things
okay so Bishop g2 or night g3 hmm I'll
go with this not that it really matters
probably gonna go here no matter what
anyhow so I'll retain some options with
my knight
I'm not so sure where he belongs in fact
I pointed out f3 h3 there's even eetu
bishop here is pawn eventually coming up
and then Knight to e2 just to steer stay
clear of this diagonal so I should
probably get on it right away
yeah all righty
I have Queen checks here sometimes you'd
see a computer do that so should I
like a computer we'll see
- like provoke something but I'm never
quite sure what the what the big story
is with that like it
c3 rc6 I don't know how to really
exploit that or if I could see something
like if the bishop laid here then that's
a problem because Queen b3
and then there's an issue with b7 but
okay let's see Knight h3 I'm wondering
alright so this this is really the first
moment where I have to do some thinking
because I want I want to see what I
wouldn't what would be an efficient way
to complete development here I don't
know if my bishop really wants to come
outside of the pawn chain for example
playing to f4 he's a bit vulnerable to
of be five pushes and I don't want that
to happen with tempo and that would be
the exact case if he comes to have four
and g5 I don't think he'll survive long
on that Square he'll be questioned
quickly so having said that I think I'm
gonna go with III and 92 and go with my
bishop I guess do a double theme cut oh
let's see Queen a4 after the game I'm
gonna do something a little bit
different than last time I'm gonna have
some computer help
so we'll get to see what stock fish has
to say about this game won't miss any he
won't miss out on any tactics so what
about efore wait a second why am I not
considering efore at all I could play
that
however do I want to open up this
diagonal a bit for the bishop and this
file for the rook not so sure about that
efore takes takes takes bishop here
after castles if I move my knight
there's gonna be Bishop h3 that's a bit
odd or a bit awkward for my development
so I don't think that's a good idea
let's go with e3 spent enough time on
that move so I'm gonna go here no matter
what next
I'll see what black does probably
castles as best just to remain flexible
Queen b3 might be interesting soon you
know the one of the main drawbacks with
the Dutch is the weakening of the
diagonal as well as the seventh-ranked
since this guy is no longer on his home
Square to to things that are potentially
weakening for black so a queen on b3
hits it this and there's a c5 discovered
check but I don't know how great that
really is what would like to on Queen b3
I wonder Queen feed 3 like I could maybe
even consider switching up move order
like c5 first but I don't know about
that c5 and if takes then Queen b3 or
even takes on b7 and then Queen b3 or
should I just go with something very
normal like Knight to e2 is there a
reason to still delay his development
just be a little bit careful about my c4
pawn but you know what Black's not going
to do anything against this point until
c6 is played I imagine c6 is not long
off
I am actually quite tempted to try this
Queen B 3 hmm I'm gonna want to give it
a shot the aggressive direct punch at b7
looking for c5 exchange and maybe maybe
after this check flushing the King to
the corner after this exchange I'll of
course not have to worrying and all
about an e5 break at my d4 point if I if
I could exchange off my C pawn for this
D pawn in other words and here's another
thing after c5 if d5 well I'm not I'm a
bit more inclined to deploy my knight to
f3 since E 5 would be weakened let me
give that a shot when I get this in if
he goes to the corner well he's this is
looking much more long-term but he is
that much further away in a more
simplified ending so don't sing I don't
have to do something this is definitely
not the way to go
I could say that much because it blocks
in the bishop I'll gain access to the e5
square I'll be taking here Queen
recapture and then a very smooth the
Knight f3 my biggest concern at this
point piece wise is my Queen Bishop
these guys are all in his way shouldn't
have problems with any of my other
pieces and as far as time is concerned I
don't think there's a big time issue
development wise I need one two three
more moves before I am fully developed
before my rooks are in direct contact
and black needs a few more moves as well
so I have a good presence in the center
I have a clear diagonal I have this
Knight under control which is nice I
control him he's not so easily activated
and because of that his Bishop won't be
so quick to see the world okay
I think I have to follow through here
yeah let's do that here's another thing
you know what I'm seeing I'm seeing some
tricks with I definitely I mean let me
let me emphasize this I definitely want
to put my knight on f3 now for sure
because even if II five is defended
there's our are the ideas tied in with
my queens placement on b3 so Knight
let's just get that right away under 10
minutes so Knight g5 starts to maybe be
a bit scary and on top of that a knight
on g5 may not be so easily kicked since
the king is now in the corner on this
h-file Knight g5 if h6 i could think
about h4 ideas maybe you know what
discovered tricks takes on g5 i
recapture the knight would have to block
on h5 or h7 he's still my biggest
concern piece wise sometimes just having
one poorly placed piece could spell some
trouble for you for that for your whole
team really so offering a queen exchange
normally i'm a big fan of that but i
don't think so here for one i don't want
to allow him to have doubled isolated
pawns excuse me i don't want black to
saddle me with double isolated pawns and
i don't want to capture and help out the
rook
so hmm i wonder
i'm gonna avoid that exchange go here
watch over efore make sure I could get
castled maybe this Queen is uh could she
be a little bit of a bug I don't know
about that she's probably going in the
wrong direction doing that hmm I'm gonna
castle next move on Queen a6 I could
think about Queen exchange still about
under a situation where I'm not helping
out a rook who would be better in a
queenless position
not so sure I still like having this III
in d4 structure functions well to limit
the bishops mobility I might want to
even consider some Knight maneuver but
this is more into the more long-term
maneuver I think I should get on with
the moves I know I need to make and one
of those is castling a reason to not
castle a reason to stop knight before
I'm not so sure about that
let's get castled there castled there
one move away from completing their
development I want to bring it to a
point where I'm going to move away a
night before night before probably Queen
e2 that seems most natural my initial
thought was night before Queen b3 but
then Knight here could be a bit of a bug
I don't know that I want to allow Knight
for Bishop exchange although this
bishops not so great so yeah that's my
that's my quick plan here I'm trying to
keep up a little bit more with the clock
the first well last week's game the
other 15 - game I was living off of the
increment and if any of you in the
comments were saying that I was playing
calmly but that was not it was not fun
and I was not calling it was not a fun
experience to be living off of increment
so let's see I could do this but the
bishop will probably advance let's try
and stay on top of the clock is what I'm
getting at here um what about Queenie -
hmm oh you know it's maybe being prepped
here Knight D Knight here I might want
to get this tempo in hmm
I could be a bit annoying actually right
here Bishop c4 I move my rook and then
Knight B 4 into here that starts to
become a bit awkward for sure I think I
want to stop 95 how we look in pawn
break wise like if c5 is played can I
get this move in I can but only after
Knight d2 of enough support to me to c5
push with this I don't want to allow
this Knight to move so easily I think
that would be a favorable exchange
Knight d5 takes takes the bishop is
opposite here I don't really like that
hmm 92 and I make a move 92 night before
Queen D 1 and then maybe Queen a6 the
Knights gonna be sneaking in here not
really liking my position oh you know
what I could do a three and a 95 I could
play Knight g5 and on Knight takes
Knight I could take the bishop I like
that much better there we go
you know that happens a lot I was giving
a lot of thought to some backward move
or just some move in general and then I
come up with
well not then I come up with some move
that I've given very little thought to
and then just pull the trigger on it
quickly
it keeps the knight out of my position
with tempo so there's something to be
said for that maybe although you know
what I was saying on 95 Knight g5 but
what about Bishop f4 Bishop c4 first and
after my rook moves only then Knight
here we might have some tricks though
knight Knight a four hits the Queen and
this Bishop oh there's Bishop here as
well why was I not considering that I
don't think there's much to fear though
I could be gaining tempo on these
whether it's a queen or a bishop that
arrives on b3 or c4 I could be kicking
them away with a 92
and they want to do anyhow just unmask
this bishop we're both in a similar
situation here on the kingside some
symmetry here with our King side minor
pieces I think both both of us would
really like to have our Knights move our
King Knights move so the bishops can see
so he's under control what about Knights
c7 to here this Queen is maybe a bit
awkwardly placed then hmm she might run
the risk of getting trapped I thought
you might do that
so Queen exchange I usually like them
Queen takes bishop takes he's a bit of a
bug I could kick him away though I go
Queenie to Bishop c4 don't like that
let's see no exchange Queens Knight d2
and after the bishop moves I'm gonna
play B 4 and then rook B 1 looking for
some minority break all right there go
the Queen's there go the Queen's and
let's make sure this little buggers out
of here he's stopping my big plan here
to play b4 yes I called him a bugger
he's a bishop and he's annoying he's
stopping what I want to do so he needs
to find a new home where will his new
home be so now this Knight not so easy
to move them b4 I should probably throw
that out there real quick tactically
vulnerable now hang on I was thinking
this move might be a pain but Black has
some some some concern over there b7
pawn you can't do that so easily I was
concerned for a moment about when I
played this move that my knight might be
tactically vulnerable he's now
unprotected and now I want to make sure
I'm in a position to do what
to me a five with b5 they're gonna get a
night in here can't really do much about
it alright I'm gonna do this a night
here
um this night playing here I might
actually move 92 just so just so what so
they continually step on one another I
don't want to exchange I think it'd be
helpful to black if I exchange a pair of
Knights a Knight d5 could I play 90 92
it seems super slow
in fact on night on this night 2d 592 a
5 could be played and that's a that's a
giant pain hmm there's also tricks with
the night just getting into this square
I think I have to start calculating
tactics mmm
yeah I need to start calculating tactics
here on 92 a 5 I need I think I'll need
to take and have stuff against b7 or
night c4 to d6 ok it's gonna start to
get crazy town I think let's let's shoot
for this one 92 less than 5 so they got
about three minutes on me gotta step it
up a bit or these exchanges a 5 is a
testing move but I'll get my activity I
may lose my a pawn although no my
bishops there to defend gotta watch out
for this square he's the most fearsome
piece on the black side to me jumping
into c3 if he thinks about going
elsewhere he's also unprotected on e too
so going to this half open file there
might be tricks here one day
although he's able to recapture from
that point so maybe any other piece if
it's a bishop okay I'm happy to see that
move actually what about a for looking
for b5 a four-night a6 Bishop a3 if I go
here right away I'm not threatening
anything and I'm just getting in the way
of tricks
what about Bishop b2 and this rook here
now I think I want to do this this b5
Bishop a three-night C for a for Bishop
c3 Brooke FC 1 b5 night C for hitting at
d6 something like that I don't think it
was a wise decision to move this rook
here we'll see what the computer has to
say though I'm missing anything after
this move I have the pawn breaks under
control pretty sure okay that weakens
this square I'm gonna go here he could
get the door slammed right on him I
realized that with b5 but B 5 week and
c6 so I want to get my last piece
working then
then another this pawn break of b5
starts to become difficult
Brooke F 2 c1 is what I'm thinking
where are the tactics should really put
the tactics cap on right around here
because things are living up for sure
and could liven up even more after a
before push hmm what is the night up to
what is he up to I should probably get
on with what I wanted to do here the
bishop could play today - that's nothing
though repeat ooh - see - or something
soon as this night moves I'm much more
inclined to do this are they gonna play
this smooth actually on d5 I have b5 a
discovered attack against the rook this
Knight can't he's once again in the way
of this bishop hmm uh-huh that's
interesting trying to trade you're
trying to trade could I really be a bug
and try to get in like a Steph 3 and E 4
who ma'am just to stop light square
Bishop exchange a weakened XIII f3
Bishop h6 King f2 rook e8 I have this
Knight move and then an h4 move I'm kind
of tempted to do that
mmm this square is so weakened now if I
do that don't like weakening that hmm
what about let's go with this not the
light square bishop exchange and this
move is facilitating a b5 advance I want
to activate my bishop
and if this move is played I think I
might drop back to this square I have
this square in mind maybe at some stage
92 here - here he's watching over it
it's an interesting piece here it's not
on c7 stopping this pawn break well it
was for a bit but it's back on
if look back over here I could still
play I could still think about b5
because this would be unprotected this
was probably a bit inconvenient for
black to have a major piece tethered to
the defensive upon I mean it's not
attacked just yet but you might as well
anticipate it being attacked where might
I be vulnerable I see these Knights
offsetting like I can anticipate it a
knight exchange one might view my bishop
is the bad bishop but I'm not so sure
how much better this Bishop would be in
comparison because he's gonna again he's
gonna have some pressure here so this
was my idea to take here I think it's a
good choice yeah I want to take yeah I
want to take do I yeah I want to take
because hang on let me double-check here
yeah I want to take because I don't want
to allow the capture and pull my Rilke
on this diagonal I'm pretty sure I want
to follow up with this push alright
there might be some
icky stuff happening b5 c5 and if takes
night here could get wild
I'll let black chew on that one I don't
want to spend any more time I need to
open the data for my bishop I need to
open the files for my rooks just a quick
practical decision there it may just be
correct but it could get complicated is
what I'm getting at with this move and
the knight jumping in here on c5 takes
on c5 takes knight here if I take the
bishop recaptures and gains a valuable
tempo hmm if I could come out like if
they get the if Black gets the exchange
if I could get a pawn and return I'll be
happy even there would be I guess
looking a bit more long-term some
possibilities to hold a position like
that if we could liquidate all queenside
pawns I think okay so forget about that
I have no worry of that anymore I should
have been on pre move with that so this
structure will now be there for ever and
this Bishop is now restricted in fact I
don't see how he really gets activated
how could I improve my position I'm
expecting a 5 but on a 5 I could think
about B 6 with then rook b5 to challenge
the Knights position this must remain
still a problem for black I have a
healthy pawn island of 5 over here all
watching over one another he's
unprotected are not unprotected he's
isolated some tricks here is that what's
being lined up hmm keeping this tension
King F 3 g5 might be annoying what about
h4 first let's go with h4 just to stop
this I'm not saying I'm doing this move
just to play King f3 but maybe one day
it's going to be helpful to secure a
king on f3 position for at least a
little bit and if black really wants to
get in h6 g5 that would open up the H
file maybe there's something to do
against the king there
alright so rule reversal here the bishop
defense and now black is ready to
compete for control over this this C
file but I could take and after the
recapture I have this move rook c6
hitting the pond and keeping pressure on
d6 I could also consider Knight here
keeping pressure on d6 I'm going to be
living off of the increment soon I want
to get rid of that night I get rid of
them please about here right away now
let's take and then here now rook c6
let's get active any tactics here takes
takes rook takes two pawns for the piece
I don't think it's enough hitting any
six keeping pressure here I want to get
rid of that Knight he's still a monster
on a5 I've rook b5 yeah that's important
if he goes back here I'd really like to
see that running in Reverse no pressure
on e3 anymore
gets in the way the bishop what's a more
testing line rook c8 giving up upon
trying to get activated over here that
might be something because if I move my
knight then Knight e3
rooks rook on the second rank hits my
knight and if I move Knight I take C 3
rook c8 rook takes a rook c2 rabito
would be needed and then I'm still I
still have pressure on this if this rook
is going elsewhere
we'll see what black comes up with about
a minute advantage Black has hmm I'm not
sure what other candidate moves there
are four black I'm really just if these
rooks don't try to get active I think
I'll be able to pick up a pawn without
too much problem I want to keep pressure
on the position if I could eliminate
this Knight be really happy how would we
fare if this position was stripped down
I had a pawn up and it was just the
bishops on board so all my pawns are on
dark squares there might be a way for
black to hold if this pond could somehow
get to d5 the King would have to come
over quick I can play my pawn up to d5
and those type of endings just bishops
on anchoring upon a d5 controlling a
light square black boxing the King out
and keeping this pawn fixed on a dark
square hmm they are drifting closer to
my time now what are they considering
here hmm it's a very passive move if I
play rook takes pawn Knight c6 that's
just one attack against my rook I could
play rook b3 I'm just gonna snip that
pawn
let's see anything wrong with that get
rid of their past pawn I'm up a pawn now
and the next phase is to get this rook
up to b7 keep pride he's the only one
who's not doing as much as he can well
now that's that's not that's not
accurate
this Knight could do better right now
he's just stupid he's not really doing
so much all right I don't want that rook
to get active so rook see one
let's go through it see one so supreme
that in a trade rooks I have a more
active rook if these if these two rooks
are exchanged and he's passive he's
active I'll be quick to get back on a3
and get my Knight to c4 with fewer
pieces on the board
oops was oh no what did I just do
fewer pieces on the board this this
tactic against two III he becomes less
likely okay why did I take that off a
pre move so we're both going to be
living off of the increment we're both
under 30 all right I should probably get
back here right away
copy I don't see a better Square mine
idea is simply what let's go here I want
to stop Knight b5 on rook a 7 there's
Knight b5 here we exchange bishops and
then I'd want to get my knight to c5
okay um should I do here
let's go here maybe I could get to f4
that would be a really good spot okay
let's do something else I could get I
could get there in a different way like
he I've pressure on this soap on push
doesn't work oh they missed that I just
saw it at the last second - I have
pressure on that can't go too far either
I got the bishop they're gonna be
resigning now I imagine time pressure
down no playing on
all right let's can keep pressure on
this point here six get that night away
yeah actually why would they resign when
there's still very little time on the
board in the game so let's watch out for
any sneaky stops I want this Nikki stuff
I just want to stay defended and they
resigned okay let me go in - let me go
into analysis mode here okay there we go
let's have a look and see what the
computer has to say with this one so had
a Dutch where were there any blunders or
big shifts with the evaluation it's
roughly equal up to this point again
there were plenty of different setups I
could have been going with here this
King Knight a reason in other words I
guess the short story there's a reason
to delay the King Knight's deployment
when compared to the Queen Knight many
different options f 3e - age 3 - f 4
maybe even G 5 so I took a while to get
him going I got this Queen B 3 move
there doesn't seem to be anything wrong
with that here doesn't have any issue
yeah nothing nothing big is jumping up
we have this exchange it wants to go
Knight G to E - instead of Knight f3 hmm
not sure still about roughly equal here
boy did the exchange Queen C - the thing
is popping up just yet
a tough fight it's a pretty dead equal
up to this point here and this is where
things are heating up hmm 95 this is the
first point that I really want to look
at here move 17 computer suggestion is
to go Bishop to b2 so anything wrong
with what I did
there's a slight shift and it likes
black a little bit like negative 0.36
one of the suggestions was king to g7
another one is Knight to be 6mm Knight
to b6 trying to get into this square
okay I did this is what I did not like
Knight takes 90 bishop takes and if I'm
taking here this night he was strong he
was strong and even in the endgame when
these pawns here had already advanced
and there were some open files this
tends to be a bit of a nuisance here
even though this c5 idea mighty might be
on the cards and then jumping in here
who knows if there's gonna be Forks on
this e to square but okay I would the
exchange
look there it still likes black edging
there's got to be stuff this is and this
has turned out to be a pretty even game
okay I didn't like that Knight move it's
liking something else like activating
the rook but still nothing serious like
Knight c3 okay and now okay yeah this is
starting to shift actually this uh these
next moves I guess it did not like
Bishop to d5 because of the move Knight
c3 and there's there's starting to be a
pull for white like more than a half
pawn advantage it's close to a pond
advantage actually I guess this is a
strong pawn break that I now have some
more support or now that I have enough
support for b5 it's going to turn out to
be quite strong this Bishop getting
activated both rooks getting activated
and his pawn structure is uh really
doing a lot against the against blacks
dark square bishop so this is where
there's probably some improvement on the
black side it likes playing Bishop a2
typical computer stuff
then it says rook a one I guess there's
oh that's it now this is interesting
even even if the main intention is to
play Bishop here now that's interesting
to first insert this and then my rook
has to go to one of these two and notice
he's on the same diagonal as that bishop
now and only then drop back to d5 if you
really wanted to do that it still
suggests here but maybe there's some
tricks against my rook now that he's
opposite the dark square bishop so
that's interesting but Bishop d5
immediately this is where there's now
pull and it's already having white as
about a pawn and a half advantage you
know had a couple breaks and now it's
just starting to climb with B takes well
it says B takes a6 right away but I
wanted to stop g5 I guess I should have
gone with that right away but it's you
can't see it the evaluation but it's
saying that it's around plus two because
that pawns gonna fall yeah it's just
collapsing so really before we even got
to this game this out more simplified
ending there were other adjustments in
that middle game I don't know if
anything else was missed any other
tricks these exchanges the evaluation is
just growing here around +3 and yeah
that's collapsing here easy to miss that
lateral movement by the rook but that
middle game position tight one here all
the way up and to this point it's pretty
even even at this point here it start to
get started to be a bit critical Knight
b5 is another move looking to jump into
c3 hmmm yeah in fact tonight b5 this is
what it suggests on the white side to
give up the light square bishop oh I
would not want to do that not at all
this could have been a bug Knight here
getting it to c3 what would be wrong
with this
Knight b6 looking at this a Foursquare
and if I can't get in a four I'm going
nowhere with this a little bit of a
minority attack on the queenside so
still when it was just the Queen's
basically exchanged each of us Queens
gone and just one pawn each are these
little night maneuvers trying to get
into a four or c4 or c3
tight game little tight game but this is
where it's shift I rifted I really like
seeing that because it was strictly
defensive but yeah I got that b5
break-in and this is where I really
started to pull ahead only after those
pawn breaks but interesting game as
always hope you guys got something out
of this and feel free to share any
feedback about the game in the comment
section below
take care bye
you